♪ ♪
>> Katie: "THE NEW YORK TIMES"
LAST OF HER BIAS AFTER A LEAKED
TRANSCRIPT REVEALED ITS NEW PLAN
TO GO AFTER PRESIDENT TRUMP.
THE PAPER'S EXECUTIVE EDITOR
FORCED TO HOLD A CRISIS
TOWN HALL MEETING AFTER LIBERAL
BACKLASH FOR CHANGING A HEADLINE
ABOUT RECENT SHOOTINGS FROM
"TRUMP URGES       TRIGGER UNITY
"TRUMP URGES       TRIGGER UNIT"
"TRUMP URGES       TRIGGER UNITT
"TRUMP URGES       TRIGGER UNITO
"ASSAILING HATE BUT NOT GUNS."
THE EDITORS THING WE BUILD OUR
NEWSROOM TO COVER ONE STORY AND
WE DID ACTUALLY WELL BUT AFTER
RUSSIAN COLLUSION FELL APART,
THE EDITOR SAYS THAT EDITOR'S
FOCUSING ON A NEW ISSUE.
REGROUP AND TAKE ON A DIFFERENT
STORY.
THE TRANSCRIPT IS REVIEWING BUT
IT SOLIDIFIED WHAT WE ARTIE
KNEW.
>> Jesse: WAS REVEALING, THEY
ARE NOT AS INFLUENTIAL AS THEY
THINK THEY ARE AND THEY ADMITTED
THEY ARE PARTISAN ACTIVISTS.
REAL JOURNALISTS WOULD LOOK, HOW
DO THEY RUSH A HOAX COME INTO
BEING?
THEY ARE SPENDING OUR TIME
LOOKING BACK.
THEY HAVE TURNED A BLIND EYE TO
IT AND THEY ARE NOW LOOKING AT
WHAT ELSE CAN TAKE OUT TRUMP.
RACE I DON'T BELIEVE WE'LL HAVE
THE SAME TYPE OF EFFECT AGAINST
THE PRESIDENT AS THEY WERE
SHOVING DEBORAH YOU CAN SEE THE
RATINGS FOR THE CABLES THAT
PUSHED THAT HULKS ARE NOT
REBOUNDING AS THEY APPROVE IT TO
RACE.
APPROVAL FOR DONALD TRUMP AMONG
HISPANICS AND BLACK AMERICANS
SINCE JANUARY HAS ACTUALLY GONE
UP.
IT'S ALSO NOT A VERY INSPIRING
MESSAGE TO SAY THAT THE COUNTRY
IS FOUNDED ON RACISM, IT'S A
RACIST NATION, AND WE NEED TO
DESTROY IT AND INSTITUTE
SOCIALISM IN ORDER TO HEAL IT.
THAT TYPE OF MESSAGING TO THIS
COUNTRY IS RACIST AND THAT TRUMP
IS RACIST AT ALL TRUMP VOTERS
ARE RACIST ARE GOING TO TURN OFF
THE VERY VOTERS THAT THE
DEMOCRATS ARE GOING TO NEED TO
RECAPTURE THOSE RUST BELT
DISTRICTS IN ORDER TO WIN BACK
THE WHITE HOUSE.
RACE ISN'T GOING TO WORK.
IT'S GOT TO BE HEALTH CARE,
EDUCATION, AS JUAN SAID, AND
JOBS.
>> Katie: JUAN, YOU LOOK LIKE
YOU HAVE SOMETHING TO SAY.
>> Juan: WE DO, YOUR HONOR.
I WANT TO SEE MY TIME TO
MR. WATTERS.
RUSSIA HOAX.
DID YOU MISS THE ENTIRE MUELLER
REPORT THAT SAID RUSSIA
INTERFERED IN THE 2016 --
THERE WAS NO FINDING OF ANY
COLLUSION, NO INVESTIGATION.
IT WAS A INVESTIGATION TO
CONSPIRACY.
>> Katie: AS A JOURNALIST, DO
YOU THINK THIS TYPE OF
CONVERSATION --
>> Juan: I SAID THAT I WOULD
SEE THE POINT TO JESSE BECAUSE I
THINK HE IS INDICTING HIMSELF.
>> Katie: AS A JOURNALIST FOR
MANY YEARS, DO YOU THINK THESE
CONVERSATIONS ABOUT ACTIVISM ARE
APPROPRIATE?
>> Juan: I THINK YOU LOOK AT
THE NUMBERS.
WE HAD A POLL AT FOX THAT SAID
TWO-THIRDS OF AMERICANS THINK
HE'S TEARING THE COUNTRY APART.
THAT INCLUDES MORE THAN 60% OF
WHITE AMERICANS.
SOMETHING IS GOING ON IN TERMS
OF THE SOCIAL FABRIC, AND IF
YOU'RE A JOURNALIST, HOW COULD
YOU NOT PAY ATTENTION TO IT.
TO MY MIND, YOU KNOW IT'S LIKE
THIS IS NOT A NEW TOPIC FOR THE
TIMES.
"THE TIMES" HAVE BEEN COVERING
IT.
THIS IS SOMETHING THEY NEED TO
DO.
I THINK WHAT YOU HEAR IS WE PUT
A LOT OF EFFORT INTO COVERING
MUELLER AND THE CONSPIRACY
ARGUMENT, JESSE, AND I THINK
THEY DID A PRETTY GOOD JOB.
THEY WERE WAY AHEAD OF OTHER
PEOPLE SAYING --
I THINK THEY WERE AHEAD OF
SAYING, AHEAD OF ALL THOSE
PEOPLE THE OTHER CHANNELS
FEEDING THIS CONSPIRACY.
THEY WERE NOT IN THAT CAMP.
>> Jesse: THE OTHER CHANNELS
FOLLOW EVERYTHING WRITTEN IN THE
TIMES.
>> Greg: THE CONSPIRACY IS
THAT THEY ARE CREATING A
FRAMEWORK TO SHAPE THE NEWS TO
LAY OUT A BLUEPRINT SO THAT YOU
CAN SLOT IN THE STORIES ABOUT
RACE.
THE POLLS SAY THEY THINK TRUMP
IS TEARING THE COUNTRY APART,
IT'S IRRELEVANT.
IT'S THE MEDIA THAT'S CREATING
THE NARRATIVE THAT PEOPLE HEAR
ABOUT.
THE FACT IS THE CURTAIN IS
PULLED BACK.
WE SEE THIS AND WE ARE
SURPRISED.
THE MEDIA SMIRKS BECAUSE IT'S
BEEN THIS WAY ALL ALONG.
RACISM IS A QUANTITY WHERE IN
THE DO -- THE MEDIA, THE DEMAND
EXCEEDS THE SUPPLY.
THE SLEEVE ARTICLE, I DIDN'T
READ IT BUT I ASSUME IT WAS
WELL-RESEARCHED, PROBABLY WELL
DONE BUT I DIDN'T READ IT.
MY ASSUMPTIONS ARE THIS IS ALL
PART OF A GREATER NARRATIVE TO
PAINT DONALD TRUMP AS RACIST.
I'M GOING TO LOOK AT EVERYTHING
THEY DO HAS SOMEHOW ARTIFICIALLY
CONSTRUCTED TO DEMONIZE
SOMEBODY, AND IT'S NOT GOING TO
STOP.
IT'S GOING TO GET WORSE WE HAVE
TO ADMIT THIS COUNTRY OVERTIME
GETS LESS RACIST.
DO YOU THINK WE ARE LESS RACIST
NOW THAN THEY '60s WERE '50s
OR 1860s?
IT'S GETTING BETTER BUT THEY
DON'T LIKE THAT STORY.
THINGS ARE GOING SO WELL THAT
THEY NEED TO DEMONIZE EVERYBODY.
THIS IS BIGGER THAN WATERGATE.
>> Juan: I THINK THINGS ARE
GETTING BETTER IN TERMS OF RACE.
IF I COMPARE WHERE MY FATHER WAS
TO WHERE I AM, I DON'T THINK
THERE'S ANY QUESTION.
BUT I WILL SAY, LOOK.
>> Greg: AND YOUR POINT THERE.
>> Juan: ANYONE WHO'S COVERED
TRUMP KNOWS HE'S HAD TROUBLE
WITH THE RACE ISSUE ALL ALONG.
FEDERAL SUITS ABOUT HOUSING
DISCRIMINATION, THE BIRTHER
MOVEMENT.
I COULD GO ON.
I WROTE A BOOK ABOUT THIS A YEAR
AGO.
THAT HAS NOTHING TO DO WITH
SOMEHOW IT SUDDENLY DISCOVERING
DISCOVERING --
IT'S BEEN AN ISSUE WITH TRUMP.
>> Greg: IF YOU TAKE EACH OF
THOSE SEPARATELY, THEY ADD UP TO
VERY LITTLE.
>> Dana: ON THE RUSSIA THING,
A LOT OF PEOPLE THAT WERE GOOD
NEWS, IT WAS A LOT OF TIME,
ALWAYS HINTING THAT TRUMP WAS
BEHIND IT.
THE PODCAST, THE THINGS THEY DI
DID.
I THINK THERE IS A GENERATIONAL
CHANGE IN THE NEWSROOM.
THERE IS A GENERATIONAL CHANGE
WERE NOW I THINK IT'S PARTLY
BECAUSE OF THE WAY UNIVERSITIES
TRAIN JOURNALISTS NOW THAT THEY
ARE ACTIVISTS AND INSTEAD OF
REPORTING THE NEWS.
NEWS ORGANIZATIONS USE TO BE
WORRIED THEY MIGHT MAKE THEIR
ADVERTISERS MAD.
HE WORKED IN MAGAZINES, RIGHT?
THEY ARE NOT GOING TO LIKE TO
SEE THAT ARTICLE NEXT TO THE
PICTURE OF THEIR GREAT PRODUCT
FOR THAT WAS THEIR WORRY.
NOW THEY ARE WORRIED ABOUT THEIR
OWN REPORTERS.
JUST REPORT THE NEWS.
BASHING THE MEDIA IS A
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT.
WHERE IS BERNIE SANDERS,
FIGURING OUT A WAY TO GET HIS
BASE ENERGIZED, BASH THE MEDIA.
>> Greg: "NEW YORK TIMES" IS
NO DIFFERENT THAN MEDIA MATTERS.
THEY ARE BOTH PUSHING AN AGENDA,
POLITICAL, IDEOLOGICAL AGENDA.